any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable in magic
welcome everybody to today's episode of
the into the impossible podcast I am
you're a fearful host Brian Keating the
professor of physics at UC San Diego and
also the co-director of the arthur c
clarke center for human imagination
where this podcast originates and
today's a special treat because again
how often do you get to interview one of
your best friends in the whole world
who's traveling all over the world as we
speak
doing a mission of peace and trying to
unite the world through his work he's my
friend none other than the Robert De
Laurentiis joining us today from sort of
in some sense the midpoint of this trip
but geographically we'll talk about
exactly how that's unfolded Robert how
are you today where are you joining us
from I'm in Gatlin Sweden Brian which is
an island off the east coast of Sweden
making my way towards the North Pole for
my crossing that's probably gonna happen
sometime in July so you set out months
ago to unite the world in a very special
mission and that mission took you to the
bottom of the world a place that I've
been to I've also been to Sweden looking
for my own Nobel Prize we're not going
to get into that although you did pay a
visit to the to the Museum they're
trying to snag me a copy of replicas at
least that's probably the closest I'll
ever get to it nowadays
tell us where how the mission originated
not just here in San Diego but where did
the idea for the flight around the world
in the so called peace pilot that you're
now undertaking Paul - Paul where did
that come from what what caused you to
come up with this idea as a mission for
your own personal for your own personal
desires but also for the global desires
that you have Brian you know I've
written a book called flying through
life and one of the premises of the book
was to pursue the impossibly big dream
and after the 2015 circumnavigation of
the planet along the equator
we you know reflected back on the
successes we had what we learned and we
wanted to continue to pursue that
impossibly big dream so after you've
done a circumnavigation of the Equator
the next logical thing to do is to go
pull the pole front in my case South
Pole to North Pole and you know we
thought that was going to be relatively
similar and set aside about six months
to prepare for that and were humbled
several times in the process because we
kept realizing it was many times more
difficult to across the South Pole so it
was delayed a total of 18 months and now
finally I'm in route I've been on the
road for about seven months waiting for
the temperatures at the North Pole to
warm up my good buddy Bryan Keating had
told me the optimal time to cross the
South Pole and of course you were right
so you know I had planned to stay in
Europe for a little while and I didn't
expect that the coronavirus would hit
and make things you know more
challenging for our film crew and for
the effort but I'm dedicated to the
mission and my 90 sponsors of which you
were one so thank you for that and you
know things are looking good the citizen
of the world is behind me here and it's
in a museum hangar for the first time in
its life so we're really proud of that
it's ready to rock and roll and you know
take on the North Pole actually the
magnetic north pole the true North Pole
and the North Pole of inaccessibility
Wow when's the what is the latter one
the north pole of inaccessibility I
think people know the magnetic pole they
know these existence from the existence
of a compass needles twist they know
perhaps the geographic North Pole is
where Santa Claus lives no it's a it's
where the Earth's axis goes through the
two poles it's the axis of rotation of
the earth but what is the pole of
inaccessibility the north pole of
inaccessibility is the center of if you
imagine the landmass around the waters
of the North Atlantic there it would be
the absolute furthest point from all the
different land masses
I see probably explain that better than
me but I think that you did a good job
there you have the similar concept the
South Pole is not the most inaccessible
part of the Antarctic continent what is
in your mind when when you set out to do
this this mission you mentioned a film
crew can you talk a little bit about
that I'm more familiar with your books
that we're going to get into especially
your recently released children's book
that we'll discuss but tell the audience
a little bit about what is the plan for
this documentary that you're
participating in you know it started out
as a 45-minute documentary and we had
hoped to film about five terabytes of
film and right now at about 2/3 of the
way through the trip were at 10
terabytes and so we decided we would
make it into a docu-series and I have a
very talented film crew a guy named
Jeremy Liz Elle and Kristen gates and
Jeremy used to work for Discovery
National Geographic and Animal Planet
and the name of the docu-series is peace
pilot to the ends of the earth and
beyond and it's about the historic polar
circumnavigation of the citizen of the
world that you see behind me it's about
the spiritual lessons that we learn in
life from flying and it's about the
experiments that the citizen of the
world carries and the records that you
set so it's also a scientific mission
and I know that you've partnered with
scientists from California from NASA
other institutions can you tell us a
little bit about the scientific mission
that that the citizen of the world is
conducting yeah I'll angle my screen
down so you can see the NASA logo off to
the side here as you know Brian you were
instrumental in making that happen the
scientists at UC Santa Barbara provided
me with a wafer scale spaceship which is
mounted inside the Citizen of the world
on the copilot side window and in the
future of space travel they're not going
to send heavy rocket motors with rocket
fuel and astronauts into space rather
they'll blast these small circuit boards
that are about the size
of your hand using electromagnetic
cannon a railgun out into space at the
rate of you know up to one every 15
minutes and it's just a much more
efficient way to explore space the one
that we have on the citizen the world
measures temperature takes pictures
altitude speed location and a few other
things so it's really the first trip of
this little way for scale spaceship
outside the campus of UC Santa Barbara I
know it's been up in a drone and a
balloon but we're literally taking it
you know hold the pole to the farthest
reaches of the planet so South right
behind you there and then eventually
it'll only go into interstellar space of
a pass the other planets in our solar
system and so I think you might have to
rename the aircraft to be the Citizen of
the universe after this so it's it's
it's really wonderful that you engage in
this tell us a little bit about what you
know this podcast focuses a lot but not
exclusively on science science and as
you know my old joke about you know
whether or not you know a scientist is
outgoing or the way to tell if a
scientist is outgoing is that he looks
at your shoes when he talks to you
instead of his own what do you what do
you see as the as the importance of
science and having this mission as part
of your flight and and do you believe
that science can work as Alfred Nobel
did towards the betterment of mankind
maybe perhaps through even pursuing
peace the science have a role in Europe
you're not a scientist you're a
layperson scientifically although you're
have a great interest in science and I'm
going to give you an honorary PhD
someday I'm sure but I'm ready to
receive it brother
dr. dr. Zhen violet but tell us a little
bit about about what is the value of
science as you see it in the agitation
towards peace well you know until I
received my degree from you I'll be a
citizen scientist and you know we're
also carrying a particle experiment from
Scripps Institute of Oceanography that
for microfibers and it was just
coincidental or lucky that I was in
Spain during the in the epicenter of the
corona virus in Europe and one of the
ways we got me out of there was letting
the Spanish know that we would
potentially be able to test for corona
virus on those plastic particles in the
atmosphere and that it was important
that I leave at that moment in time you
know to test for the the plastics and I
think that these world issues cannot be
solved by an individual or a country or
even a brilliant scientist it takes the
world working together so in that way
you know science brings us together and
when we look at our mission of one
planet one people one plane we see that
the global issues that we face you know
pull us closer together and I know from
talking to you that you know all the
matter and the universe came from the
Big Bang so you know the cosmic material
that makes us up unites us and just like
we have you know global issues that we
deal with as a planet we're also
communicating globally right now right
so communications connect us the economy
connects us with other countries so we
are we are citizens of the world whether
we like it or not and I think that
dealing with these challenges also
creates opportunities to bring us closer
together and that's a lot of what this
mission is about so I want to take a
little step back and go over your
history and we've known each other
coming up on ten years now I can't
believe it it's really flown by since
you weren't a pilot when I first met you
and now you've not only tripled
quadrupled how many flight hours I have
in my my extensive flying career such as
it is what gave you the courage to do
this mission and the previous mission
which was to fly you know horizontally
the quote-unquote normal way that most
people do it I think there's probably
exponentially fewer people that do what
you're doing right now in terms of
circumnavigation what is it mean to you
what is the planet the planet mostly is
me
Oshin you were a lieutenant commander in
the United States stable a navy and I
wonder you know has this always been
this wanderlust to traverse the world
has this literally been going through
your veins since you were a little kid
or where does it come from and do you
think you'll ever be able to scratch
this itch for exploration yeah that's a
great question Brian I you know had
certain goals in my life I wanted to
make a certain amount of money by a
certain age and you know get to a point
in my life where I could go and do
things above and beyond you know just
make a living and I was blessed
at about age 35 where I felt like I
could you know start to move in a
direction of retirement and give back in
another way because I was thankful for
what I had been given so what I try to
do is just bring together my different
passions which were my business
spirituality and flying and in doing
that you know I decided that I wanted to
fly and further and further with each
attempt and then finally you know the
world was my focus and the plane is
really a billboard for our message and I
was taking a course in spiritual
psychology and I was talking to my
instructor and we were talking about
exceeding you know our life's
expectations and I told him I was
looking for a mission and he said how
about world peace and we both sort of
laughed at that because it seemed
unreachable but as time progressed you
know and I got some experience it
started to see like seemed like
something that I could you know make an
attempt at and I didn't want to just be
somebody who sat behind my computer you
know I wanted to go out into the world
have impact and just like you did with
your biceps experiment at the South Pole
and your experiments in Chile I just
felt like it was important to go in the
world and make an attempt myself you
know certainly people promise us they'll
do things for the world but this was my
opportunity and I figured that even if I
failed it still would have some impact
fact I would learn and hopefully inspire
someone off so I guess you know having
the opportunity to go out into the world
and make a change is the thing that
really got me moving talk to us about as
we often do we talk to the ultimate
performers in the world of science but
also in the world of art writing etc you
mentioned your spiritual psychology you
know which which you and I have had
discussions about and you know how
scientific is it and how does that fault
in but one thing that is unquestionably
gleaned in my experience from reading
your previous two books and now your
book your children's book which we're
reading to our children from uncle
Robert and we have we had a previous
edition which was the coloring book
which is a collector's item now because
it has the wrong dates on it that's at
2018-2019 so that's becoming it's like
that first stamp you know with this
plane flying upside down by mistake but
so that's a clear night we're never
selling that that's how we're gonna make
our retirement fund but it's priceless
by the way I know but one thing that
that you've talked about a lot you know
it's like Zen has become really you know
a little bit overdone lately in some
ways meditation you know I was joking I
had on a very well-known researcher and
author named dr. Judd brewer on the
podcast last month and he was talking
about you know he's got meditation apps
and he and I were talking like you know
something might might have passed its
prime is when you know Puff Daddy now
has a meditation app or you know and I'm
sure he's a very zen zen guy and very
chill but but you really had to deal
with things that tested the theory and
the practice you know it's it's some
things work in theory but they don't
work in practice and I'm referring to
your the event that took place in in 20
close to 2015 right and your
circumnavigating the globe equatorially
and the plane that you were in the
single-engine piston powered plane went
down over the Strait of Malacca and you
almost lost your life and it was very
frightening to me and my wife and my
friends and
all of our mutual friends how did you
deal with that what kind of impact did
that make on your life and how did it
change just your approach to what we
call risk management at the citizen of
the world has two propellers that's
probably not an accident right well my
good friend Brian Keating had told me
before I left on that trip that I should
have a plane with turbine engines
because they were a hundred times more
reliable so behind me I had two turbines
and I'm taking your advice but on that
first trip you know I think the engine
out over the Strait of Malacca at 14,000
feet I think that that was intended to
break me and you know in a spiritual
with a spiritual perspective you could
say that that breaks you open and then
you're actually ready to receive you
know the lessons that you were intended
in life and much like my trip to the
South Pole and the citizen of the world
behind me I felt like that that broke me
you know it took me beyond my limits and
at that point I think I was finally
ready to be open to the messages and the
lessons that were out there for me you
know it's not necessarily a comfortable
experience but I think it's necessary
one I saw it for you as you said this
kind of brush with death that led to a
rebirth it was sort of this turning you
know within you that now kind of
catalyzed the new movement because
before I felt like the mission made
sense even nobody has to explain why
human beings want to explore the world
you know perhaps before for their own
purposes that are in wanderlust their
desire to perhaps have new opportunities
in different places but again as I said
you're in the Navy for many years during
the first Gulf War you saw a lot of the
world you probably you know didn't need
to do that the way that you know
somebody a landlubber like myself might
who hasn't seen as much of the world so
I don't think it was for that but it was
for a mission you did it with the
children of San Diego in mind and now
you're doing it with children all over
the world so I want to talk a little bit
about children and your various
contributions as I said this this
coloring book is just delightful we have
this is one of our many copies it has
the citizen of the world it's
beautifully illustrated I'll put links
to the books talk to us about your
recent book with with Susan Gilbert what
what did you guys what was your
intention with that book and and what
has been the reaction to it so far you
know Brian let me address one of your
earlier comments first the Zen pilot
branding evolved actually I don't know
if you can see this on my collar but it
says peace pilot yeah and you know I
think as I've evolved the branding he
has evolved and Susan and I to answer
your second question wanted to put
something out to the kids of the world
at the point where they're first being
inspired to fly and if you look at
general aviation today they're focused
on high school kids because in a few
years those kids will be flying but I
think that kids are inspired much
earlier than that and I was in Africa
actually the shopping center at a
restaurant and there were two adults and
there was a little girl and there was a
plane flying over and she looked up and
pointed at the plane and her parents
didn't even notice you know they were
just going about their business and I
thought that little girl has just had
her first exposure to aviation so we
wanted to do a children's nighttime
story that spoke to the kids at the
level they were at and somehow planted
that seed for you know their future
exploration for their dreams to inspire
them and I think we were fairly
effective with that book the little
plane that could and you know of course
it's uh has a reference to the little
engine that could that we all grew up
with but there was nothing for aviation
and we wanted to be the ones that to
plant that seed in the minds of little
kids everywhere of course it also
reminds me a little bit of this book
about aviation which also has little in
it the little prince
I don't know but as an adventure story
and that you know kids really take to
this notion of the underdog or the or
the the grand mission in life and you
know in a few minutes we'll get to the
big picture questions that I ask all my
guests but but looking at it and in
terms of wanting to inspire people
especially young
people when you get them when you're
young you're doing a lot of work with a
AOPA correct yes and if you could see
the nose of the citizen in the world you
would see their 80th anniversary logo
it's the biggest one on the plane and I
had made a promise to the senior people
at AOPA that to help them celebrate
their 80th anniversary I would cross the
South Pole in 2018 oryx correction 2019
which I did so yeah a OPA is sort of the
central cog for I think all pilots in
the United States yeah I've been a
member for decades now hopefully they'll
get a copy of this video but I want to
say in this confluence between children
and aviation you know it's often said
you know there are as you mentioned you
know kids are naturally interested in
aviation but at least in the United
States the population of pilots is
getting older and older and I wonder how
in your opinion can that be best
addressed through the work that you're
doing with AOPA aircraft owners and
Pilots Association I should actually say
it for 99.9% of my audience but the but
why do you think aviation on one hand
the popularity is seeming to decrease
whereas the popularity of spaceflight
you know has just never been higher and
people are so excited about it
what how do you reconcile these two
different trends they used to go kind of
hand-in-hand the right stuff in aviation
would translate into astronauts and an
interest in flying to other worlds what
do you make of this up of this
oppositional trend where you know
general aviation popularity is is
declining somewhat and maybe drastically
you know wetter than I do and it's also
getting older and older so that the
population isn't replacing but
spaceflight is getting even more popular
especially with young people I like to
think that aviation is sort of the first
step on the way to space travel and I
believe most astronauts not most but
many of them you know start off as
pilots and to answer your first question
Brian the way we're trying to reach out
to kids to help inspire them is I am
working with red bird flight simulators
which is the biggest flight simulation
company for GA pilots in the United
States
they have 3500 simulators worldwide and
we'll be doing five flight simulations
for them so any child or you know
aspiring pilot will be able to get into
a red bird simulator including the full
motion ones and actually experience the
citizen of the world and fly to the
South Pole so we're super excited about
that I like to think that the citizen of
the world will be a mobile classroom and
for kids to help inspire them and I'll
take it around in different museums like
the Bungie Aviation Museum that I'm at
now we have some interests from the
Smithsonian as well and the kids will
literally be able to touch the plane get
inside the plane and you know experience
this magical aircraft that's gone old a
pole on a polar expedition so I think
you know getting the plane out there in
the world will be a good first step
certainly there are challenges of
opportunity you know time and money for
aspiring pilots and the DeLaurentis
foundation will help sponsor some
scholarships for kids to help get them
involved in aviation as well you know
the the the trip is extremely expensive
and it's using a lot of the resources of
the foundation but at the completion of
the trip then we're going to shift some
of those resources to kids and
scholarships that's wonderful and then
sort of the last part of this of the
travel log so to speak portion before we
get on to the big picture of life
questions that I ask everybody so
literally where do you go from here
you're gonna go towards a fly over the
North Pole the different poles in about
a week or so and then when you return
here to our hero's welcome that we have
planned for you in San Diego well as of
this morning
the schedule or the flight route changed
because I was headed over to Iceland and
then up this fall barred Norway and we
found out that the camera crew can't get
into Iceland on the 15th so we're trying
to get special permission so that they
can fly into Oslo and then go up this
fall barred Norway which is the northern
island you know for
Norway and then go over the pole into
Alaska and then from Alaska I have a few
stops along the way I'm going to meet
some people that have been instrumental
in making the pole to pole flight happen
from there I go into Canada and do some
interviews with respect to an electric
aircraft it's being tested there and
then down into Seattle Washington to
meet with my mentor Susan Gilbert who I
know you have spoken with a few times
and then into probably San Diego
International possibly with Eric
Lindbergh the grandson of Charles
Lindbergh if we can still make that
happen and then back into San Diego how
it's a Gillespie field therefore if we
think that'll happen
probably by late July early August at
the latest so we mentioned Space Flight
a couple minutes ago do you dream of
going to space do you dream about
extending not just you know the mission
of the De Laurentis foundation but do
you have do you have dreams or
aspirations of going farther into space
or do you feel like your most important
work is here on terra firma you know my
most important work right now I think is
the next leg and Eric Lindbergh sure to
thought with me he said that the only
thing that matters is your safety in
your life right now but once the trip is
completed I certainly want to see you
know how far we can take the lessons
that we've learned but to answer your
question directly Brian I would love to
go out into space I don't know many
people that would turn down an offer
like that I was watching something on
YouTube a couple nights ago and just the
views are spectacular so yeah it's quite
a chance to interview dr. Jessica Muir
while she was on the space station back
in January and you know she's my highest
flying podcast guest but you're my next
highest funny and fastest flying - right
yeah she certainly was fast flying and
now she's back on earth and the mission
really has changed her in many ways I
don't think she could have anticipated
her stories quite quite amazing and I
hope someday to encourage her maybe
if she needs any help from somebody like
me but to encourage her to write her
life story because I think that that
such such adventures are inspirational
and they really are the best way that we
can communicate to the future
generations what we thought what we felt
and store wisdom you know kind of like
fine wine and had the honor and pleasure
of having not only Carl Sagan's daughter
Sascha Segan who is an author on my
podcast but about a week ago ahead and
Riaan who is Carl Sagan's Widow and
partner and all things related to cosmos
and I relayed you know the famous
statement that Carl Sagan said that
books are proof that human beings are
capable of magic and that we write these
little squiggles on paper and then a
hundred years later you can have some of
these voice in your head that might not
be alive anymore and yet you could
benefit for his or her wisdom so I want
to turn to the various books you've
written and and just ask you how did you
come up with the idea for the title I
always judge books by their covers no
matter what people say how do you but
the covers the title and how that how
did somebody propose it to you did it
just come to you in a flashing career
let's start with jibt Zen pilot we can
go flying through life and then the
upcoming of the children's book how did
you it well you already mentioned how
that came up so how did the first two
book titles come to come to you well you
know it's funny Brian because I'm
reading this book by Charles Lindbergh
now this is a 19 I think 30 Edition and
I never even knew about this but he's
talking about his early training as a
pilot but to answer your question flying
through life was actually a creation of
Susan Gilbert we mentioned her earlier
and it was her idea was a concept or a
sort of an umbrella that encompassed the
three passions of line which was the
flying the business and the spirituality
and you know that still remains and this
pole to pole flight fits neatly
underneath that but it was 19 spiritual
concepts that I incorporated into my
business and then it tripled in size mmm
and what I wanted to do was go out into
the world
and not just talk about that
show that the concepts worked and I
would do that by doing that equatorial
circumnavigation mm-hmm
and then during that circumnavigation
had the ancient outer of the strait of
malacca that i mentioned and that's when
a Zen pilot the book came into being and
the Zen pilot portion was sort of a a
reflection of what Richard Bach had done
back in the 60s he was incorporating
spiritual concepts into our daily lives
but he was doing it in such a delicate
manner that nobody was spooked by that
right because sometimes when people get
a little too spiritual or religious it
sends people running for the hills so
Zen pilot was a way to take the Zen
moments out of the flying experience and
share the things that we can learn about
life from flying hmm and then of course
the next book will be called peace pilot
to the ends of the earth and beyond just
like the docu-series and the peace pilot
to the ends of the earth is the South
Pole in North Pole but the beyond is the
spiritual component of this trip and we
know that the North and South Poles are
the only two places on the planet where
peace is always existed so the goal of
the mission is to connect those two
places and everybody in between on this
mission of world peace so it all fits
very nicely together to help promote
peace in the world that's phenomenal so
then the next thing I asked about books
is would you rather have a hundred
readers a year from now of any of your
books or one reader a hundred years from
now
hmm I just love to have one reader now
and it's not because we haven't sold a
ton of Zen pilot it's because you know I
think people can influence other people
and really all we can do is be the
example and if there's just one person
that gets that lesson and goes out into
the world and I think our mission has
been accomplished and certainly you know
we want thousands or millions of people
to read it but you don't know if that
person you expire or inspire is going to
be you know a Martin Luther
so somebody could read the book like
maybe your kids Brian or reading or
working on that coloring book and they
go you know what I want to be a pilot
and you know my dad teaches me about the
universe I want to go out and I want to
fly when I become an astronaut I want to
write books like these guys you know you
just don't know where it's gonna go
yeah so I think it sounds like the
number is not as high as maybe what you
would expect but I think if we can just
inspire one person to go out in the
world and make a difference that could
be the difference in matters no that's
wonderful so now I'm gonna ask a couple
of questions related to sort of the deep
future of you and your legacy so the
first one in revolves around what's
called an ethical will not a material
will are you gonna leave you know your
vast riches from from flying around the
world and the plane parts and the books
and everything hopefully I wish you
great financial success obviously but
but I'm more interested now in your
ethical will what wisdom what what what
facts about you know the human soul or
spirit as you've studied what do you
most want to convey to a future
generation you know I thought about that
Brian in the 60 minutes that you gave
give me a heads home work I'm more than
I get most my student pop quiz really
you know what I came up with was just
honor your word and it sounds like such
a you know a basic concept but it's such
a foundation for everything that we can
accomplish in the world and you know you
and I have had business dealings and I
like to think that the first promise I
made to you I honored and then from
there you know the friendship deepens
and then we progress into new territory
and we get closer you know we we share
what we have in terms of your knowledge
and you know the resources that you
helped to contribute and it just grows
from there and it just I think builds
trust in the world and I think it helps
bring about peace in the world too
because if you can trust what somebody's
told you and they're gonna honor what
they do I think you can have you know
great impact builds for this
there's a notion at least in Judaism you
know I'm a practicing Jew and that when
somebody goes to on a trip a friend will
give him or her a dollar to give to
charity and ordered to do something good
once they get to their destination and
the theory is that you know you can't be
you're sort of protected or made more
safe I mean obviously this is not
scientific but the notion is very
beautiful that you're kind of protected
when you're on a mission and that God or
spirit or whoever you want Zeus or
nature Darwin is pretty you know is
protecting you in order to ensure that
the good deed that you're on a mission
to accomplish will occur so it's a nice
sweet tradition again you know you can't
take it too seriously
but it's but it's it's a beautiful
message that that you're on a mission
and I should contribute to that as I
hoped I did in a small way to ensure
your safety and that you actually
complete it because I think you you have
this very lofty goal for yourself and
for the world so I think that's that's
quite and it's quite beautiful
the next question revolves are always
gonna say Brian I also have something
for you and I'm going to tell you that
I'm flying it to the ends of the earth
on this polar circumnavigation and I'll
let you know that it's a world peace
coin oh and we have 200 serialized coins
on the plane and they may smell like jet
a1 by the time you get it but that's
okay
it'll be infused with the energy from
this trip and the planet and the poles
and I think it's going to be a pretty
magical thing to LA and have look how
far it's traveled literally so actually
the next thing does May dovetail nicely
into that so thank you so much it's very
beautiful the next topic that I ask
guests is really a flashback to the
movie 2001 a Space Odyssey which I hope
you've seen where there are these
monoliths these mysterious objects
placed throughout the solar system that
mankind is meant to encounter and then
it's supposed to you know teach them or
warn them what have you but I like
think of it as kind of a billion year
old time capsule something that you put
in a time capsule err on it perhaps some
achievement whatever I've had a lot of
different you know responses given to
this question what would Robert what
would you put on your billion year long
lasting time capsule maybe my scorns I'd
put the citizen of the world here
because by that it'll be they'll be paid
off and it has all the you know modern
technology of the day and I think it
represents you know the hope and the
courage and the desire of the people of
the planet and you know it's it's a
beautiful plane but it's doing something
that I think exceeds the expectations
not only of myself because if you would
have asked me if this was even possible
a couple years ago I probably would have
you know laughed and said yeah good luck
with that you know but I think it's it
has the energy it's been infused and I
think it's a magical instrument of
learning and knowledge and of peace yeah
that's very wonderful and you you
priests aged my final question which is
related to the title of this podcast
into the impossible which is one of us
or arthur c clarke three laws of the
universe which in this case is the only
way to find out what's possible is to
venture beyond it a bit into the
impossible and i like to ask my guests
you've accomplished so much what
mysterious thing or thing might have
seemed impossible and when you were in
your 20s and 30s like many of our
listeners are but then then you went
ahead and you did it and and now you
know that it is possible i would say
would alluded me me back then brian was
what is my purpose and in my life when
my purpose and my passion came together
then there is an acceleration and that
acceleration or that purpose is I think
this trip that I'm on now and I reflect
back and I think about all the things
that are contributing to my success and
they happened you know throughout my
life
and I didn't really understand which
direction I was going back then but I'm
now very very clear that this mission is
critical not just for my development but
for the planet and for you know all the
people on the planet so I think having
faith and you know different religions
sort of guide you in different ways but
I think that element of faith is
critical just believing that what's
happening to you now you know in the
early stages of your life are intended
to get you to the place where you're
going to go yeah
well that's really lovely rubber the
last thing I want to say is like your
propellers I want to put you into the
spin zone now and ask if there's
anything you'd like to promote where can
people find you on the internet your
books etc well they can find all the
books on Amazon and I would direct
people to social media if you type in
Zen pilot or Robert De Laurentiis you're
gonna find us on Twitter YouTube
Instagram Pinterest Facebook and then
our website is ww2 T Oh pull again
flight so pull the pull flight and
there's hours of reading and pictures
and all kinds of information and they're
all easy ways to contact me fantastic
well as I said it's always a treat to
talk to any of the guests and all the
guests that I give the privilege to talk
to I think to the impossible but it's
super fun when we get to talk to a close
friend and in this case it's none other
than the man my kids call uncle bro Burt
for kind of brother and Robert mixed
together we can't wait to hug you back
when you return to San Diego and I want
to thank you for sharing your time I
know it's getting late there in in the
parts of northern Europe in which you're
currently inhabiting wish you all the
best not just of course in safety but in
achieving the the impossible dreams that
you've set for yourself and I just want
to salute you for your courage and and
being one of my best friends I wish you
the best I miss you and I can't wait to
see you back here in San Diego you know
Brian thank you really which keep the
thing that keeps me in
fired are people like you you know that
support and encouraged me along and you
know you've been a supporter since we
first met many years ago when our
bromance officially started and you know
I I think about you guys I see your logo
on the plane and I appreciate all the
love your family sends my way so thank
you they do love you thanks Robert
well if you can't tell that was a great
treat for me a little emotional talking
to my friend flying around the world I
want to thank everybody for being fans
of the podcast for being subscribers I
want to point you to resources you can
get on my website Bryan Keating comm
include show notes etc join my mailing
list I send those out about once a week
I promise not to overload you and spam
you if you like this video leave a
comment like it subscribe it as all the
youtubers tell me to say and I'll keep
making them and I've got a little suite
of guests coming up in the next few
months I know you're all going to enjoy
and I always appreciate your feedback
leave it in the comments below and stay
in touch thank you guys all so much any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe comment
share rate and review for a chance to
win a free copy of our most recent
guests newest book send a screenshot of
your review to info at imagine UCSD edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to you suggestions for
future episodes for more information go
to imagination dot UCSD edu find us on
twitter and imagine UCSD watch us on
youtube listen on itunes into the
impossible is a production from the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the University of California
San Diego
Eric veeery director Bryan Keating
co-director Patrick Coleman associate
director produced by Stewart Valco